and we decided that we were not going to
wait on government any longer we were
going to be
the solution
we're going to be the answer to the
violence and the poverty in our
neighborhood
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bring to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as we possibly can to build a center
here on this block there is much needed
called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od pierre who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up the oldest name and
started calling it o block we decided we
want to keep the o but we're going to
call it opportunity block i want to
thank fox for giving me the opportunity
every day to bring to you rooftop
revelations my thoughts my viewpoints
and opinions as it relates to what's
going on in the city of chicago and
around our great country
i want to tell you
something about project hood and how it
got started
so many people around the country have
been sending in emails and text messages
and asking me the question
so i want to take you back to
2011.
in the month of november there was a
young man named carlton archer 16 years
old who was shot and killed
when he was shot and killed his parents
did not want to have the funeral at our
church because they were afraid of the
violence that might occur
and i assured him that nothing would
happen but
sadly to say something did happen
on that day when the children from three
blocks away were walking into the
neighborhood
the kids in this neighborhood started
shooting at them because they were
opposition at one another
we were finally able to get
down thankfully no one got shot and
killed and we were finally able to have
the funeral
cops were everywhere
young people were everywhere and at the
end of that funeral i never will forget
i stood up and i made an announcement
something that i had never felt before i
felt a nudge of god
saying to me that young men had brought
guns to that
to our church illegally and i needed to
get those guns and i stood up and i made
an announcement that listen
i want you to turn your guns in
we're going to do a gun turn in today
and i said a prayer
and i appeal for those illegal guns to
be turned in
do you not know that on that day four
guns were turned in
as i walked out the door
i never will forget i told the lord
whatever you want me to do from this
point on i'm going to do it
and as i looked across the street
from my church walking out of the
funeral i saw this motel
this was 10 years ago
i saw this motel where there have been
prostitution and drug dealing and gang
banging and
all kind of illegal activity and i
decided
with an urge
an unction a nudge
from the holy spirit from god to go up
on the top of that roof
and stay there
and i thought it would take just a
little time to raise the money to buy
that motel
but it took me 94 days
on the roof of a motel 10 years ago
to raise enough money
to purchase that motel
and tear it down
i was there
through all the holidays november the
20th
to february 24th
i stayed right there fully committed but
while i was there
i started studying
and trying to figure out why did we have
all of these issues
in our community why is our community
labeled the most dangerous block in all
of chicago
and we decided to start a not-for-profit
called project hood
hoods means helping others obtain
destiny
and we decided that we were not going to
wait on government any longer we were
going to be
the solution
we're going to be the answer to the
violence and the poverty in our
neighborhood
and we start putting in place
programs for every area
where there was a problem in our
neighborhood
our church decided that this is going to
be our mission
project hood
helping others obtain destiny
and ever since that day
we've been putting programs in place to
help people
programs in place to help single mothers
programs in place to help guys and
ladies get out of gangs and change their
lives around
programs in place for fatherless
children to to be mentored to be
looked after to be given
positive direction
we've been putting everything we can in
place
to make sure that we have
a better community
that's reason why i'm on the roof now
again 10 years later it's the 10-year
anniversary
but this time i'm not here to
tear anything down i'm here to build
something up
i'm here because we have outgrown our
space
inside of our church where we use the
whole second floor to have these
programs and
the other side to have a school
now we're trying to scale it and build
up
so that we can have a place
to totally transform our community
and we're going to do it
with the help of all the people who have
been a blessing to us
all across america
we are taking these programs
we're scaling them and we're changing
people's lives
that's what project hood is all about
that's why i'm on this roof
giving you rooftop revelations every
single day
from november 20th
to february 28th
and as i always say
god bless you
god bless america and until tomorrow
peace
you